everyone we're back with some more
farcry dark aid maps user created maps
we're gonna go through a few of them
my name is Joey yeah Jake right here
how's it going pretty good last time we
did we started off with the the roulette
I forgot the name of it exactly arcade
here arcade hero which basically gives
you a random map from anyone any
basically from anyone that's created one
and just put you in there regardless of
the quality which was fine but for this
time around we're gonna start off with
some of the cute looks like a curated
list of ones that we found so far
yeah the maps are getting good donor
we're not gonna play through all of
these we picked five from here you may
recognize this from last week Zelda
we're gonna start with showdown this
one's pretty popular it seems to be
going around the PC community as you can
see 5,000 yeah over 5,000 plays four
stars it's a neat little map gunslingers
share for hunter farmer oh let's gold
gunslinger I always like when they name
the loadouts and so just have the
assault or whatever so this is gonna be
the replacement for a Red Dead right
until yeah pretty much this is basically
Red Dead Redemption 2 right here
so got so then what look so what assets
are they using here it looks like it's
actually pulled from like a western town
but maybe that's just yeah I mean this
church is definitely from the main go
yeah you're right yeah honestly I don't
know actually you know what it plays
it's probably a assassin's creed black
flag right that would be my best guess
where a lot of these are from so is this
map is just a salt right so you got a
kill yeah just kill 26 quite a bit but
like I like how they give you enough
hiding spaces instead of just like a
plain map with just a couple I don't
know what that guy was doing taking a
little nap are you just gonna stick with
the revolver oh I got him about two for
one I guess I had the double barrel if
that's not cowboy enough I know I
there's I I wonder if someone's got a
repeater I can take this guy
maybe that guy up there on the roof
it's like he's got something good oh oh
no I died so I guess the question is do
we continue with the same map after we
die if we die I think we just roll on to
the next let's go on the next one yeah
okay all right here we are our mansion
on the beach as you can see this hasn't
been played as much around 273 plays
I've got spy equipment yeah it's gonna
take these three out getting our dune
buggy lots of people to take out we got
our first target here probably drinking
some mimosas on the beach
you can probably just run them over from
here right they just take one last guy
out okay whoa where'd that come from
who's gone now I think oh I hit on him
don't know if I kill them we're about to
find out is he down he's down oh no he's
back up what oh my gosh
waters annoying well is there another
guy shooting at you under you good good
alright now we're on to the mansion yeah
finally took care of those guys only got
one arrow left this Oh got to be careful
sneak our way in so we got to tart wait
three targets toll Oh it's gated off or
you can repeal repeal or ascend oh I
like this you know oh okay
they're both sitting down well I mean
they live in the mansion on the
beachside what else isn't gonna do a
rather empty mansion oh it's got one of
those infinity pools - look at that take
a swim all right I'm down I'm sure they
won't mind if you just break the window
all right me too I can kill this guy
first watch the sunset this poor guy is
gonna get a bullet to the head you
should know you should you should choke
him out let them LEM down peacefully all
right that wasn't peaceful a bullet to
the head probably doing more peaceful
nice so I'm wondering this guy must have
whoever made the map must have put it
together like himself I'm not sure how
extensive the the premade assets are in
the game yeah I
they're pretty extensive this looks like
oh there we go
this looks like they made this though
yeah ouch
well you have to get to the exit oh it's
a helicopter yeah no we're gonna get
there in style we jump off the
helicopter into the boat yeah I don't
know if I have look how blue that water
is oh good I've got a parachute oh no
I'm out of bounds for East fun I'm
coming I'm coming I'm coming
okay we're good good just don't try out
oh so what do you think of that one I
like that one yeah that one was cool I
wish there was a little bit more on the
island yeah I think it would be it would
probably benefit from a little bit more
a few more enemies I think yeah and
maybe like once you get to the the
mansion it turns into like like a hit
man style stealth operation where you
have like yeah the only like a couple
weapons or like just your pistol that'd
be pretty cool but yeah props to let me
see the name really quick the toaster
toaster five yeah yeah good map check
them out we'll move on to the next one
which is a metro 2018 yeah I'm a big fan
of the metro games and I was thinking to
myself the other day me and it'd be
really cool to make a metro game or a
metro map in this game this isn't quite
what I envisioned but it's still pretty
cool and I like how it's Artyom is the
class name which is the main character
in Metro nice so you start off inside
the the subway here Sarah in yeah
there's a lot of enemies though so uh be
ready
well I like the clutter yeah it it's it
is very reminiscent of Metro last light
or metro 2033 they not knows you hey
well yeah here we go oh you got two
shells left by the way I know I owe ya
another gun of course
and so this one was just a journey get
to be a good yeah it's uh it's not super
long oh she was a little bit longer but
uh it's it's pretty cool yeah one thing
I noticed is that people tend to
re-upload their maps a little bit later
on after they've done like more work on
it like a lot of times the first version
will be a person people play then then
though I maybe get feedback from reddit
or some somewhere along those lines yeah
I really wish you could leave comments
in like two Maps like I kind of
understand why you can't because you
know people are kind of jerks sometimes
but I think it's a bummer that you can't
like like there's no way still liking it
dislike you can't have someone like hey
I like this map but I think it'd be
cooler if you added XYZ yeah it'd be
nice to have a like a central area for
like constructive criticism he's
throwing the tree at you yeah in a back
away and I have no health regen it looks
like I beat this before but I'm sure I
won't beat it this time oh shoot
oh my god uh no idea of health regen
yeah
use the old med kit yeah
is that it well for now no no there's
more later but I think we're clearing
this area oh yeah these piles of junk
it's pretty sweet there's another metro
map I found too it didn't really feel
like Metro but it was like it was like
Metro yeah this one this one has more of
the ambience of the game yeah yes that's
it really short but I enjoyed it does
remind me of Metro yeah I can imagine
the creator who's uh his name is Big
Smoke I remember yeah um yeah if
possibly this could be like just the
first of many iterations of the same map
which they just continuously expand upon
koltes coasts yes so we have a couple
more left so I was thinking that one and
then maybe the island one or there was
one that you have listed on there what
was it it was called going home it
reminds me a lot of the Last of Us oh
cool but this one here is koltes kosis
it's one of more popular ones that was
uploaded today see what we got
urban woodsman urban woodsman with a
with a with a fifty caliber rifle so
this one's this one's a journey through
I think it's like yeah this coastal
outputs that's kind of it's somewhat
similar to the Wild West one that we
were playing earlier hmm
same style buildings but this is more
like corridors just got throw some c4 on
them well that hurt me no one heard that
except for him Oh
probably wasn't the smartest idea well I
got some long sightlines here
so do you anyone else that's the one yep
that's some one wow that was quite the
blood spurt
this is definitely black flag stuff yeah
it even said it in one of the tags
assassin's creed black like not played
this one so you might have to guide me
if I get lost all right I feel like it's
pretty straightforward oh geez Oh barely
got her
you like that jump Jill yeah I was good
impressed I can teach you how to do it
after we're done if you want I was like
a big open area in this spot this sniper
Rex oh geez I missed
oh geez this is just a running for huh I
don't blame him I'd run for me too
oh come on don't stop right there
Teli this is too easy for you just
running through a train through every 50
Cal I'm used to the aiming now what god
I think you may have gotten them it's a
lot of screaming all right this way
maybe those know it is gonna get hanged
all right we're gonna throw another one
of these Oh too far yes where's my 50
Cal for this guy
sturdy piece of plywood right oh that
was bad
expecting him to ah there we go it's one
way to hang someone I guess I haven't
had to use this yet I know you've just
been taking everyone out from a boat Oh
what do you think I'm gonna take Joey
mmm
this of course think so have more
maneuverability oh you gotta get through
the river
nice this is pretty cool I like the size
yeah
Oh classic leave the barrel on the
bridge only in videogames I love it oh
we got a little tunnel going here oh
she's gonna keep going here make it yeah
those barrels there yeah this is really
cool basically like an action movie
right here I'm really I'm really happy
yeah oh my god whoo that was cool yeah
that's one of my be one of my favorite
ones yet yeah so that was koltes Coast
bye Maz bot ski that's a cool one
definitely play that one uh let's do
this one and then we'll move on to some
random ones
okay get anything good this one reminds
me a lot of The Last of Us and I really
like the I don't know the settings
really cool it's it's very brief though
all right so we got so we got lip Buster
vent crawler survivor and for that
what's the Fourth Amendment so this was
called going home by I forget the name
again we'll look it up we'll look it up
to at the end but yeah this reminds me a
lot of like oh they got this guy yeah
with like all the foliage growing on it
yeah with the gigantic building all the
way in the background like always guys
over here looting see you bud so if this
is supposed to be the last of us where's
your companion maybe that's all right
can I go get her out just like break the
lock maybe is there a lock to break I
don't see one
I don't have any long range I don't know
if it's even worth going up there
yeah I really like these little outposts
or these little little shanty towns they
got Oh God
that was weird
there we go you're not getting them the
piles of rubble yeah yeah smells really
nice says pretty good atmosphere is that
still your only weapon no I have a
shotgun - shotgun
I feel like wasn't a great choice
considering there's people above me yeah
where what I've no idea oh my god
Oh how's nice well I see four all right
yeah I got some like that's pretty good
yeah I think you're good for now I don't
see any uh any other markers wait are
they all upstairs or kin or can they
even be on top of those bill no no like
they can get up high but I don't know it
so it's almost feels like they're
spotting me through the the buildings
which obviously is no fault to the
Creator it just seems like a a glitch or
something yeah
barely barely is it the edge of death by
the skin of your teeth alright so those
are the maps we picked for this week
however we're gonna spend a little bit
of time just doing random see what we
get yeah let's see yeah see how long we
can last basically not not just in the
game but like just playing Santa
possibly terrible ones over and over all
right here we go
arcade hero I don't know if I can do it
don't hit Enter oh I'll do it alright
you hit Enter you're in Alpine take down
no stars I'm not sure I'm not sure if no
stars is a good or bad I think it means
no one's really rated and no one's like
oh only nine people have played this so
this is probably the the most recent one
sapper infantry gunner sniper a stupid
honor yeah okay well at the very least
it's not a flat map it's not a flat map
which last week I said it was a pet
peeve of mine and I guess people didn't
agree with that it's I would say its
preference I think cuz like the one that
we just played was completely flat but
they yeah but like it's the ones in
nature when they're flat that are like
yeah like obviously you started shooting
at that bear sooner for some reason I
was like oh maybe want to thank me hey
obviously if you go into a forest it's
not gonna be just a flat land all the
way around yeah kind of here though
you've rushed this one he was he was he
heard you and talking about the flatness
of it so he just made sure he made all
these bumps and forgot to put the text
okay okay alright I mean if you make
your map big you can't put texture I
mean I think you can but like it
definitely limits yeah I can do so maybe
this is a very big map
I mean got a heavy machine gun might as
well use it so we've got three targets
to kill and they're all oh they're
probably all in some compound at the end
of the map
probably you just got maker away there
sniper way up there hitting me that I
can't see like you probably run to that
that's not your blood right might be oh
my gosh sure yeah crack shot where's
that coming from
I don't know oh we found the ends
there's one sniper just waiting for you
to come across the corner with a
baseball bat
you know what the edge of the world
reminds me of it reminds me of the
wooded Kingdom in Mario gout or Mario
Odyssey oh yeah I wish they had some
sort of like shell on the outside to
prove that like this is just a
simulation yeah
Alpine take wait a second this is the
same one it says only nine people have
played it though so maybe we that didn't
really happen
infantry gunner maybe it is all a
simulation this happens sometimes
sometimes I like playing map play
another and it'll go back to that same
one never two in a row though I never
had the same one twice in a row okay we
got to find' the church this was
uploaded today by mad company 224 other
people have already experienced this map
we're gonna keep the what's doing come
on
it doesn't make heavy there we go we're
gonna keep the heavy train rollin all
this is dark this is very dark all right
how many enemies we got so you think
they're zombies
we have 90 to take out so I assume I
mean it looks like a lot of effort was
put into making this look nice
unfortunately it's very dark and I can't
see a lot of it
oh here they come
oh you have a turn here
all their coming behind oh they're
coming from the cemetery is that Wow
guess that makes sense
what is your a throne item right there
looks like a thing of meat oh yeah
attract bears animal wonder if there are
any attracting so I'm just ran up to it
all did I just blow up my ammo no I've
got like new the guns still okay right
yeah I had why just picked up oh geez
all right this there's the wall never
track who's next okay you're a third of
the way there almost I spawn into one
map with 218 nm is that the max it's got
to be close to it I mean wasn't cuz I
left almost immediately I was like nope
the amount of enemies depends on I think
like I think there was like an AI limit
apparently for them yeah cuz I tried
putting um I tried making a map where it
was just beehives everywhere but it only
let me put down like 12 of them or 24 of
them because of the like a i limit i
guess on every individual bee or
something alright so far I like this map
however its it's got some issues I think
the biggest one is that it's really
tough to see sure I could change like my
monitor and all that yeah but at least
maybe like some floodlights somewhere
yeah at least in one area inside the
church I think would make it that would
be really cool actually like leave the
darkness but throwing a floodlight yeah
maybe like a floodlight
facing outward towards the door so you
can actually see a little bit on the
outside as well
Wow I don't think this is working
thank you right if you die we've made it
so far I can't let this happen
finish them off with this the way it was
meant to be played yeah well I would
have stayed in here but they started
coming and there's someone pushing the
garbage cans with you oh I thank you
it's last one
no last to see you how should I kill
this one throw the hoe at it yeah you
know there hope all the shovel everyone
loves the shovel in this game but you do
while you can actually see him alright
don't throw rocks at me come on bro okay
nice this was uploaded today out quiet
silly
let's go silly I like that that silly is
an option I really I really like that
alright so you've got an MP 44 we've got
a grenade launcher and a flamethrower
what could possibly go wrong what could
be sillier than a flamethrower
oh no they're calling reinforcements oh
my gosh I'm getting tonight this is not
silly enough I don't think that a
loadout did me any favours should we try
one more time with another load out yeah
Australia all right all right we're
gonna do quiet this time yeah oh oh oh
yeah they both have sounds cool and you
got a throwing knife oh boy they just
love playing snipers in this map
seriously
jeez I don't know how I'm gonna get
around to there um I think I need to
kill these guys yeah well two for one so
we're talking about maybe get that last
guy on the left yeah Oh God yeah
definitely
well there's a couple of them I don't
wait it's so slow like you can just
smash it you suck at hiding sir it was
the most polite enemy
oh my god we know they just don't stop I
feel like I killed I made a good amount
of them all right well I'm sure
someone's gonna comment and say I'm the
worst far cry player ever again but
that's okay
they're gonna just be typing I'm suck at
hiding Jake yeah
sir sir I could hiding sir I think the
winner today is definitely that koltes
coast though ya know who's really good
yeah I like that one but anyway I think
that it got wraps it up yeah so those
are the maps that we played this week if
you have one that you want to show off
or if you know one that like you really
really liked and is kind of getting fine
below the radar just let us know put in
the comments you can tweet at us and
we'll hopefully be able to play it next
time
you